welcome to this video God bat shook em
gabacho can only played him once before
yoga Don even offer I wonder how many
people called even off our international
masters a real real whole lot I guess
and this cheetah right is also called
even off Boris even off borislav I don't
know okay um I wanted to play this
really dry and game variation so here we
go and let's see yeah it's nothing
special but I don't have they don't have
anything great against the Queens gambit
accepted yeah I can't help it if you
give me the bishop pair i will i will
just take it
yeah there's not much going on besides
them that I have the two bishops if I've
is probably played to prevent 94
night a four and probably not leading to
much a somehow moving lots of pawns on
the King side I'm not quite sure why
exactly now I can play 95 now and then
take c5 isn't this good looks good check
getting another another bishop
he is six min I can just drop back not
sure how to continue from here it's
obviously quite nice with two bishops
against two nights but how do I am
actually proceed not quite sure maybe
King 2d to the idea for might be might
be a move try to get some concrete
counter play him
yeah I'm not not totally sure how to how
to continue deform is probably not so
great but still I'm not sure what I
should do place getting his getting some
some camel to play with that in any case
pretty much no matter what I play
what I actually had forgotten this at
age frying nothing terrible i mean in
fact that i don't think you should have
taken them time morning but he did check
it anyway
yeah widest is much better now unless
I'm overlooking something something
simple check yeah I'm just winning
winning now the the night is gone with
Bishop f3 coming yeah the endgame never
never is any good for Jack with the
chanted to bishops against her to two
nights
check what black resins and it just
shouldn't really give up giving up the
first bishop him I don't know but the
second one is really too much check yeah
this is substantially better for white
but I wasn't totally sure how to how to
play it with rook e8 there is this
counter play based on the fact that
after d 480 494 his lights are
centralized and my turn post concrete
threats and I wasn't sure how to how to
set this up sorry I was thinking that a
three before might be long-term a good
plan and it really wasn't sure about
this cam you can play rock t7 this is
something that is better for white but
probably not not in any way anyway
decisive yeah here white is somewhat
better but is it is it anything anything
substantial maybe remember fish at
amount of the famous end game with the
pawn seein against the light squared
Bishop it's not the same position but
it's close I have a bad King though yeah
well this is this is always better wine
change this this concrete case it's it's
very good you should probably take on
g21 fried with this here he is just just
totally over he has no square something
like that is also just giving up the
pony
it's two points and these are fast okay
thanks for watching